joining us now is trump defense attorney
david shone
david um the democrats obviously want to
use as much video as they can
it's awful it looks awful i think you
stipulated your team stipulated to the
fact
that it was awful and no one
condoning any of what happened on that
day
are you prepared to offer
similar compelling and emotional
uh video showing that the democrats
themselves if this is the standard
could be said to have incited all sorts
of riotous behavior
well that you'll have to stand by and
watch but uh it's a pretty good bet
i would say though that you know it's
not only that they wanted plenty of
video time today
it seems like they want a lot of screen
time for themselves they're clearly you
know
playing uh to the cameras uh to the
public
all of the time and as you correctly
said i offered to stipulate
right in the uh opening happened it was
horrific and so on and i said
you talked about unity and healing
showing
that tape over and over again the same
slides and so on
and manipulated by them does nothing for
healing
it's the exact opposite it's continuing
to open wounds
for the american public and it is
something that president trump has
condemned
in no uncertain terms the terrible
violence that went on there
so there's not an issue about that
they're just hoping to drum up emotion
and get their last shots in at president
trump but will you say tonight
that you will show because the videotape
is out there
what the impeachment managers themselves
said about the legitimate legitimacy
or worth of of a previous presidential
election namely the
election in 2016 or other words similar
to that
that could be similarly described as
inciting
unrest well you're apparently very well
aware of what's out there
i don't uh commit publicly to any
strategy that we're going to use
um i i just don't think it's wise but i
think that you'll be
uh quite impressed with the president's
case uh
and and i say that without uh wanting to
even have to do that
we shouldn't be here it's an
illegitimate unconstitutional
impeachment process completely lacking
in anything i know but you lost that
from
start done i understand that but you
lost that point i mean we get it
i mean i understand that argument i'm a
lawyer but you lost that point so now
it's on to responding
to the issue of incitement that's the
one article you have
so my i'm going to ask this question
again because i think there are a lot of
people
i know but they don't follow the law
because they don't know the law or the
law of
impeachment so they see all this video
then they see all these trump tweets
then they see the fact that he didn't
immediately come out and condemn it and
tell them to go home
and they say oh well this is just
terrible it is incitement
so you have to show that the other side
does that morning noon and night for
most of trump's presidency
you got to show that it's a chance
yeah yeah that is absolutely relevant um
you're well aware obviously of what's
out there
yeah yeah um and this is what
impeachment manager ted lou
said today david how do we get to the
point
where rioters desecrated defiled and
dishonored your senate chamber
i'll show you how we got here president
donald j trump ran out of
non-violent options to maintain power
david would he be thrown on a courtroom
any
regular proceeding for saying something
so outlandish
absolutely they would be thrown out of
the courtroom for showing this video
none of this stuff would be admissible
in any kind of court of law that's part
of the due process issue i don't know if
you saw today when senator mike lee
stood up and objected
that they falsely attributed to him
statements that he never made
and he made an objection and the whole
place sort of blew up in a hullabaloo
and finally uh the house manager
congressman raskin
said that they would withdraw it for now
and check their sources he said he
thinks their source
i don't the media they think the
washington post he might have said
but if you look at their videos and the
clips they show some report some sources
are
reportedly other our sources said that
they have hearsay on hearsay on hearsay
but he was outraged today because they
made us an argument and then repeated
the argument
attributing comments to him about a call
they said the president made to him
without ever even consulting him about
what was said in that call
can you imagine that disrespect to a
senator yeah
and schumer kind of blew it off it's
like else isn't really despaws whatever
it doesn't really affect the case but i
i it was it was a compelling way
wait yeah they've they've been telling
you how important that was
i want to ask a fair point i want to ask
one more question
given what's at stake here for
constitutional precedent
uh in the fact that they want to cancel
trump's opportunity to perhaps run again
if he wants to
have you all consulted some of the
president's previous
impeachment team uh jay sekulow and that
and that crowd given the fact that
they were obviously successful i'm not
saying you're not going to be successful
you probably will be
but have you collaborated at all with
that team
i've spoken with them yes oh interesting
fantastic david we're going to be
watching carefully can't wait thank you
so much for joining us tonight